meanwhile the race to develop a vaccine
is gaining momentum the German drug firm
bio ntek won approval to begin the
country's first human clinical trials of
a possible vaccine
there are currently dozens of potential
candidates in development in Europe
China and the US but health officials
say it will still be months before a
vaccine is ready for the market the
German firm bio ntek is working on what
it hopes will be the first vaccine for
kovat 19 an important step will be human
clinical trials these have now been
given the go-ahead by the federal
vaccine regulatory body the Paul Ehrlich
Institute the trials will be the first
in Germany with this authorization we
will conduct the fifth clinical trial
worldwide to develop a vaccine and this
is indeed a milestone with us does this
fall not in my own time bio ntek will
perform trials of four different
versions of its vaccine candidate on 200
healthy test subjects between the ages
of 18 and 55 in the coming months in the
hope of developing an effective
treatment for the novel coronavirus
Germany's Health Minister says safety is
key one thing is very important after
all this is an injection so safety must
be the top priority of seamus the active
substance in the vaccine will contain
the pathogens genetic material the human
body will then create proteins with it
against which the immune system will
form antibodies the principle bio intech
already uses we use this for a vaccine
therapy for cancer the whole project has
now been redirected along the timetable
clinical trials will start at the end of
April
first results are expected at the
beginning of July if positive trials
would be expanded to thousands of
subjects in the fall and winter the
company hopes to develop a kovat 19
vaccine this year but experts say 2021
is more realistic stinka shonda I think
it's reasonable to expect a vaccine in
the first half of next year which has
been approved by the authorities and is
widely available the vaccine doesn't
just have to be tested it also has to be
available to the general
population not just in Germany but also
worldwide an effective vaccine is one
great hope to end the corona virus
pandemic he has a look at some other
stories making headlines around the
world Boeing is thought to be planning
to layoff 10% of its civil aviation
staff news agency AFP reports the cuts
would affect up to 7,000 people working
on the 737 max and the long haul 787 and
777 models Boeing is restarting
production of the aircraft following
coronavirus shutdowns
US President Donald Trump has signed an
executive order temporarily suspending
immigration he said it was necessary to
help Americans get jobs in an economy
ravaged by the coronavirus but the order
includes many exemptions including for
medical workers as well as immediate
family members of US citizens air
pollution in the Indian capital Delhi
has dropped dramatically due to the
coronavirus lockdown leaving residents
marveling at the blue skies and clean
views back in November the Indian
capital suffered some of its worst
pollution experts attribute the
improvement in air quality to the drop
in road traffic let's have a look at
some other coronavirus news from around
the world ratings agency Fitch says the
world is on track for a recession of
unprecedented depth in the post-war
period it could be twice as severe as
the Great Recession of 2009 South
Korea's central bank says the economy
has shrunk 1.4 percent over coronavirus
its worst performance in more than a
decade the number of confirmed covered
19 infections in Singapore has passed
10,000 despite robust efforts by the
city-state to try and control the virus
in China a citizen journalist missing
for almost two months has reappeared he
says he was detained by police and
forcibly quarantined